[Applause]
oh good to have you here sir it's great
to come to the show i love the show it's
so
live and we can excited this is
excitement here baby you're in that
studio there's no one there it's just
you
what kind of bike were you on what's
that little girl's bike
i prefer a little girl's bike weird
looking thing weird i like it
um they keep it nice and cool in here
yeah we like to keep meat here on the
weekends okay
do you prefer this set up to your own
setup is this strange for you on your
side
people are but people are right nose to
nose on your show i've been on your show
and you're right there
i'm literally this close you think so
kiss me you fool kiss me
he almost did it he wanted to um uh no i
like i love audiences i like to get
reaction
our show's a different kind of show we
get very serious on larry king live
yes very musician there's not a lot of
uh uh newsmakers uh condoleezza rice
isn't on a girl's bike
on your show no wouldn't it be great if
she came in on a bike
well get her to do it all you have to do
is ask yesterday if she came in on a
bike oh yeah
oh and to the hearings if she wrote in
the mic probably not a good message to
the american people
i'm seriously trying to run the country
ring ring
anyway it's a thought i want to talk to
you because you have been interviewing
people for over
45 years uh i've been doing it here on
this show for
almost 11. but clearly you're the master
what's the key to doing a good interview
the master i'm honored uh well i'm just
saying that because you're here now but
no when you're gone i'd be like what's
with that guy
crazy to me no uh uh yeah what is the
key just made a mistake
yes no please please tell me what am i
doing wrong tell me help me the key
yes is listening the good interviewer
just said that one more time
the good interviewer must listen too
many interviewers
interviewed themselves the key to a good
interviewing style is short questions
leave yourself out of it i has no place
in an interview there's no pla it's
irrelevant
the guest counts so i'll give you an
example of a bet
can i jump in just for a second
no no i like what you said i like your
example i like
what you said but i i just don't know if
it works for me that's all i'm saying
it doesn't it may not have to work for
you but it's my show it's got to work
for me
late
what you do is you take it yeah and
apply it to you apply it so you would go
on and say
i'm a bad interviewer right but this is
me
and i'm going to do it my way you set
the tone
right for your audience because i have a
hard time i do listen to other people
but i always end up talking about myself
at length on the show and ultimately
making it all about me you're saying
that's probably a mistake
well it might keep it might keep you on
late
yeah you'll attend
i think the other key to a good
interview is uh keep it short thank you
for being here
[Applause]
of you yes and therefore you will be
more you're saying weirdos nerds and
freaks is that what you're saying
possible possible you will be more
important than your guest yes and if
you're more important than your guests
there's a place for that too i'm not
knocking it
it's three years old okay you tweet his
own two no no no you gotta have your own
style not my style
11 years is you're saying a lot when you
do 11 years yes yes but
you want an example of a bad interview
yeah okay my guest tonight is conan
o'brien conan's just written a new book
called conan o'brien's massachusetts
i've been to massachusetts many times i
love it i've been in boston
and i've been to the islands up there
offshore cape cod okay you're right
about cape cod yeah
well it's one of my favorite places cape
cod i love it cave i've had a lot of
adventures on cape new girl there once
sadie emerson owned a bar do you know
what sadie emerson actually do i think
[Applause]
that was bad no no it was effective
it was for you for me yes it was
demonstrative yes
right and the whole prospect crazy
prospector dance i did in the background
was good for me
that's right but ultimately not helping
you your guest
is giving an example of a bad interview
yes and in setting that example yes you
set off as the course so i was making
you the interviewer what you did was
smart
oh i was smart yeah because i was
interviewing mine
i'm with a child here
[Applause]
i'm like gallagher now i'm working with
props over here um
what else you want to talk about let's
talk
let's talk about you ah that's a novel
you've uh i'm going to keep this short
and uh to the missoula falls uh
why do you make fun of my you know what
i love the way you do i'm not making fun
it's my homage to you
now you know i
you know i don't hear people imitate my
voice
that way the way you do it yes i don't
hear that you don't hear that i don't
hear you know missoula falls hello i
don't hear that
right but other people keep telling me
they hear that oh yeah i don't
it's it's that bad huh no it's great
it's you you got to be you you're larry
king listen you've been doing this for
45 years you're the king that's what i
said before you came out okay
and now you've got a book remember the
idea behind you didn't let me finish
[Laughter]
you